I did a lot of jobs for terrible pay
because I just wanted to get in the room
I started video in 2003 and thank God
for my youth pastor because he handed me
a Canon hv30 camera with mini DV tapes
and Adobe Premier software and he said
start making videos for the youth group
and these things would play Wednesday
night and they were terrible I was doing
52 videos a year I'm a volunteer because
I'm here to get the wisdom I want to
invest in skills the guys who typically
have the biggest impact and the biggest
longevity in the business space have
built businesses and so it's kind of
like how tall the skyscraper is is How
deep the foundation goes